Just before we get into the video for today. Let me thank our sponsors.
Skillshare.
Is an online learning community for creators,
with thousands of classes in design business. And more.
We've talked about Skillshare a few times on this channel,
and we've mentioned the various courses and things you can learn on that
platform, but maybe you haven't got Skillshare yet.
And therefore you're totally skill less. That's a great shame though,
because there are thousands of classes on Skillshare for you to level up your
design business, video, social media, whatever skills,
or just take them from nothing to something. You can do that to
a time when so many important conversations are happening in our world.
Your voice is more essential than ever explore classes to unlock your creativity
for social good here on visual politics, we've taken video production courses,
camera courses, YouTube stuff.
We also want to squeeze out as much as possible from our day.
So we watched a course by this guy called Thomas Frank, who is also a YouTuber,
great stuff, and worth checking out if you want to get more done in a day.
So yeah, Skillshare, just go do it.
You'll like it it's less than $10 a month with an annual subscription supports
visual politic by supporting Skillshare.
The first 1000 people to use the link in our description will get free trial of
Skillshare premium membership.
So you can explore your creativity and I'm pretty sure you'll continue your
membership because it is so great. I know let's get cracking.
[Inaudible].
Do you remember the dinosaurs in Jurassic park? Well,
it is likely that in the year 2025,
you'll be able to visit them in person and Saudi Arabia. And no,
I haven't gone crazy and what's more surprising.
This is one of their brilliant strategies to save them from the brink of ruin.
That's right. When we think of Saudi Arabia, we think of millionaire, sheikhs,
skyscrapers,
and the most extravagant luxuries oil has turned this country into one of the
world's greatest.
However, Saudi Arabia is actually getting closer to economic collapse,
and I say collapse with a capital C Saudi Arabia could become the next Greece
before this decade is out.
Those of you who are veteran followers of visual politic already know why we
have been covering the crisis in Saudi Arabia.
Years.
Basically almost the entire economy of this country depends on dinosaur juice.
Crude oil represents almost 90% of this country's exports.
And if there's one product that's been affected by the Corona virus.
Oil prices.
Have collapsed. And as the price of a barrel of oil drops,
all of their income drops.
We're talking about a country that has been used to living in an economic utopia
for decades to give you an idea,
almost all Saudi citizens work for the state and conditions unthinkable
elsewhere on the planet. They barely pay any taxes.
I receive a lot of state funded days.
But those days.
Are over and now they need diversify their economy.
And this.
Is where all those great projects you have heard about common mega cities in the
middle of the desert, a Jurassic park flying cabs,
and even even an artificial moon.
So my friend's a visual politic Saudi Arabia is rebuilding itself from top to
bottom and it's doing so in a desperate measure to avoid it.
In between.
No are ridiculous investments and to capital, a lot of killing.
And that is what I said. So the question that we're asking today as well,
the mega cities really save this country from economic ruin.
Why does Saudi Arabia want to put dinosaurs in the metal of the desert?
Will they really be able to carry out such measure projects?
And did I really say an artificial moon today?
We are going to answer all of these questions,
but first let's look a little history.
The Mirage of the petrodollar in 2017 Mohammed bin Salman was appointed
crown Prince of Saudi Arabia.
One of the first things he did, as soon as he came to power,
it was to gather all the political and economic elites of the country and lock
them up in a luxury suite at the Ritz hotel in regia.
And they were all accused of corruption. Since then,
Ben Selman has been defacto, the absolute leader of Saudi Arabia,
and he has a very clear mission to modernize and diversify.
His country's economy.
Time is running out and Saudi Arabia needs to produce something other than the
sweet, sweet, dinosaur juice.
The big question is what is it really possible to create competitive companies
in this country? Well, the truth is that it's almost impossible. Yes, it's true.
The Saudi population is very young. 40% are under 25 years old.
Many of these young people could be the next Elon Musk or the Mark Zuckerberg of
the future. In fact, many of them have studied at Univerisity.
So what's the problem. Well,
only 20% of Saudi Arabian university students have studied technical careers.
Most Saudi students choose degrees such as theology,
Arabic studies or Arabic literature.
As you can imagine with that kind of training,
it is difficult to set up a rival to Facebook. In fact,
most private companies and Saudi Arabia avoid hiring Saudi citizens.
To give you an idea of the Saudi workforce.
35% are immigrants working in the oil or construction sector.
38% are civil servants and 15% are unemployment.
Only 12% of Saudi citizens work outside the state.
And yet you did hear that correctly.
38% of the workforce works for the state as a comparison France,
which is also a country that supports a huge state has only 24%.
Mondu all this means two things.
The first is that it's very difficult to get new companies started.
The second is that at the time when the Saudi state has stopped hiring more
officials, unemployment levels have scaled.
I rocketed
this 2020.
Youth. Unemployment is at 65%.
So vision 2030 is really been Selma.
Ann's desperate plan to modernize the company.
Part of this.
Consists of a
$445 billion sovereign wealth fund that invests in companies. For example,
Saudi Arabia has invested in companies such as Boeing, Facebook, and Disney,
but if you really want to modernize your country, you need much, much more than,
And since there were hardly any economic sectors beyond oil,
Ben Solman has decided to create them from scratch with mega projects.
So far, Saudi Arabia has Mecca, which is the religious capital of Islam.
Ben Salmond's plan is to build new MCAS, but not religious ones,
economic ones, the Mecca of tourism, the Mecca of biotechnology,
the Mecca of green energies.
We are talking about whole cities built from scratch cities that would make
those new Chinese metropolises that we have told you about.
So many times on visual politic look like backward village.
For example, on the red sea coast,
they hope to finish five artificial islands by 2022 and 16 luxury
hotels on the outskirts of radio, they are building cornea,
which aspires to be the capital of healthy leisure. In other words,
I kind of Las Vegas,
but with like casinos alcohol and without Elvis impersonators. So in my opinion,
Las Vegas,
without any fun with all this Saudi Arabia wants to copy the example of Dubai,
but to the extreme, however, the real jewel and the crone is the city of neon.
We're going to talk about this later and you're going to have to hold onto your
chair because I guarantee you've never seen anything like it in your life.
And I know what you're thinking now. Okay.
So now he's going to say the Corona virus has ruined all these projects, right?
Well, I'm sorry to tell you.
That you're wrong.
Clean austerity and Megalodon.
Mania Lake, almost every country in the world.
Saudi Arabia has had to pull out a Corona rescue for all the small businesses.
I've had to close down during a lockdown.
We're talking about more than $32 billion that have triggered debt levels.
And this explains news headlines.
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia VAT rate to increase to 15% from the
1st of July, 2020 Deloitte.
I know what you might be thinking, no, a goods and services tax a 15%.
That's no big deal, but it is.
If we take into account that it used to be only 5% and before 2018
Saudi Arabia didn't even charge it. In other words,
the government has been forced to triple this tax overnight. And of course,
they also have to cut all the aid they gave to several sevens. However,
it is one thing to talk about current spending,
where they have made cuts is quite a different story when it comes to investment
with or without the Corona virus,
Saudi Arabia needs to start producing more than just oil.
And one of the sectors that is betting on is real estate and part of Benz
Elman's vision 2030 goal is that 70% of Saudis will order home by 2030.
All of this indicates that the government is building new residential areas.
Everywhere.
It's the case. For example, of sauteing murkier,
a macro urbanization financed by the Saudi and Chinese governments.
The first phase is almost 6,000 new homes.
And 90% of them have already been sold.
They gave me beyond luxury housing, artificial rivers, and many, many mosques.
These are just residential areas, projects,
to some extent that are a bit average.
At least if we compare them to the jewel and the crone,
Ben Salmond's personal pet project,
what could easily be called the most ambitious project in the history of
mankind, check this out.
The city of the future.
Let me present to you. The city of neon. It does not exist yet,
but supposedly in the year 2030,
the whole world will Marvel at the biggest city in the world,
built from scratch and the metal of the desert.
[Inaudible].
We're talking about a city of 26,000 square kilometers,
but we'll make it 33 times bigger than New York city.
Imagine the whole territory that Belgium or Maryland occupies covered entirely
with skyscrapers,
New Alma aspires to be the Mecca of tourism technology biotechnology,
and a lot more.
And all of this with zero two emissions into the atmosphere and ecological
environmentally friendly synergistic, and 2.0 city,
by the way is curious that the country of oil and fossil fuels they know,
want to make a city free of CO2 emissions. But that is another story.
And you're probably thinking why, who would think the building,
the largest city in the world in the middle of the desert would be a good idea.
Well, as strange as it sounds in principle,
it could make economic sense to prove it, take a look at it.
[Inaudible].
We'll look at it. New home is located on the red sea coast,
which is where 20% of the world's Meritain traffic passes through.
It could easily be a logistics hub and addition.
It would be the ultimate tax Haven.
They could even consider greeting a Zune without taxes of Annie Kane,
a special economic zone,
independent of the government of Saudi Arabia and managed directly by Mohammed
To all this we add to the country itself would finance the first wave of
construction. We have a good place to invest, and you're probably thinking, uh,
no one lives on that land.
Can they really start building there without having to buy the land first? Well,
the truth is that it is a practically unpopulated area.
The only inhabitants of that region are a pneumatic trade. The Al who waited.
But remember, we are talking about Saudi Arabia,
a country where human rights are best optional, preventing Selman,
displacing all these new mines is as simple as saying,
get out of here or I will send in the army,
But just how ambitious as this project. Well, at least on paper,
the idea for the new home is to have a Jurassic park with robotic dinosaurs,
but that's not all,
they've also said that they're going to have an artificial moon.
So yet I did see that. So why do they need an artificial moon?
You might ask what return on investment and an artificial moon give you well,
I honestly don't know, but Ben Solomon has said he wants an artificial moon.
So he gets an artificial moon. And what about the beaches? Well,
you see the beaches themselves are already beautiful.
We all love to see the sea and the waves, but what if we could make the waves.
Shame.
Neon will also have waves that glow in the dark. It may seem incredible to you,
but it is in fact possible to make the sea glow in the dark,
which is a sentence I honestly never thought.
I'd say apparently there was a type of unicellular algae that when it reproduces
without control generates a toxin that glows in the dark,
have you searched on the internet,
you can find incredible images in Taiwan or California,
where they have suffered plagues of bioluminescence of this canine.
This is a spectacular phenomenon, but at the same time,
our real problem as the name indicates this toxin that glows in the dark is
toxic. That is, it kills all the flora and fauna in the water.
And I'm not sure how this fits in with the idea of making a completely green and
environmentally friendly city, but who is going to argue with Ben Sellman?
And you're probably thinking, no, well, what about the roots?
What are they going to do with the cars to prevent them from polluting the
atmosphere? Well, don't worry, but in Selma has thought of that painting.
I don't want pavements in roads. In 2030,
we will have flying taxis quote, attributed to Muhammad bin Salmaan.
This is just a taste of everything they want to do for the city.
The schools we'll have teachers who teach through holograms.
The streets will be cleaned by robots and there will even be cameras on every
corner, monitoring the citizens to give you an idea.
The concept of neon is to create a model of what human life and the future will
be. And Ben Solomon is more than ready to make that model, whatever.
It takes.
At the time of making this video,
Niamh already had an airport built and running.
They have just built a water desalination plant with the capacity to process
50,000 cubic meters of water per day.
And despite the austerity brought on by the Corona virus,
Saudi Arabia has already seen a lot of contracts with construction companies
between March and September of this year. But the question,
the big question that you'll all be asking is,
is it really fair to call it a Jurassic park? If the dinosaurs are animatronic?
I'm kidding. Of course.
The question you're wondering is how much is this monstrosity going to cost?
Well, remember I told you to hold onto your chairs, do that. No,
because the budget to build the home from scratch as $500 billion,
$500 billion, that's the equivalent of Belgium's entire GDP. As you can imagine,
Ben Solomon's idea is not to finance this all from his own pocket.
Heaven's new Saudi Arabia takes the first step,
but the rest of that money should come from international investors at the end
of the day,
who wouldn't want to invest in such a promising project. Well,
right now we're going to look at labs.
Selling is bad for business.
As strange as it sounds when Ben Salmaan a nose to the neon project in 2017,
many people said they would join in and we're not just talking about any
millionaires. Richard Branson said he wanted to invest in Norman foster.
One of the world's most famous architects also said he wanted to build the
city's first skyscrapers in the end, as crazy as this idea science,
it is still a very inspiring project,
especially if you're a Richard Brunson or Norman foster type who wouldn't want
to be the first to build a city with artificial cabs, dinosaurs.
And I see again, an artificial Mooney. So yeah, back in 2017,
Naomi seemed like a good idea, but in 2018,
something happened that changed the perception of the project forever.
The CIA concludes Saudi crown Prince ordered Jamal Khashoggi, his assassination,
Washington post.
Oh, the start of this video. I already told you that Ben,
some man had no qualms at all about putting the entire political elite of Saudi
Arabia in prison. Although that prison was a luxury hotel, what's more in 2017,
Ben Selman kidnapped the Lebanese prime minister.
We've covered the field story and another visual politics video in case you're
interested. And after all, why wouldn't you be?
But this is already on another level.
Homolka Shogi was a wall street journal journalist who was very critical of Ben
Selma.
One day he entered the Saudi embassy and Turkey and he came out,
cut up in little pieces in plastic bags.
Ben Solman literally ordered him to be killed and quartered.
As you can imagine,
anyone who may have been interested in doing business with Ben,
Suleman abandoned the idea at that point,
it was no longer a question of ethics, but pure survival.
Would you really dare to have a business meeting with Ben MUN,
knowing that you could be killed at any moment? In fact,
Ben Salmaan himself seems to have understood that this event doomed his project.
This is what he said in 2018.
No one will invest in the neon project for years,
Mohammed bin Salmaan.
I imagined him saying that crying while washing the blood off of his hands.
And now I ask you,
what would you do if all your potential investors turned their backs on you
because they were afraid you were going to kill them.
Maybe a good idea would be, I don't know,
to stop killing all the people around you,
but instead when cell mines decided to call cause Shockey's relatives to have an
official photo taken.
With them.
He then for Bates Shuggie son to leave Saudi Arabia and Ben Salmond's personal
killers, the so-called Teicher squad continued to threaten all study activists,
living abroad. Meanwhile, in order to clean up his image,
Ben Salmaan has dedicated himself to organizing sporting events in neon.
The city is not yet built and does not have any stadiums instead of big soccer
competitions. They have organized extreme sports events, wakeboarding,
paragliding, wingsuit flying. And not only that,
remember that new home is the city of the future.
And what is the sport of the future? Exactly killing activists. No,
I'm kidding.
[Inaudible] signs MOU to become global E gaming hub Arabian
business.
You may have heard in 2019 Ben Salmaan St.
A contract to sponsor world cup events of e-sports such as Dota two and league
of legends. And that does sort of fit with gamers like myself,
image of the world. I mean, yes,
he might be quashing political distance and murdering people, but at least,
at least he's not charging for microtransactions. However,
this ingenious plan has not turned out as he thought,
do you remember that trade that lives or rather use to live on the land where
the city of neon will be?
That's the Al who wait out to trade and many members of this trade do not want
to leave the land.
They have lived on for centuries for the construction of the project.
[Inaudible].
In other countries. When these things happen,
there are lawsuits and governments compensate the owners with large sums of
money. This is something called private property. However,
private property in Saudi Arabia is like human rights.
And that it is very much an optional, extra.
[Inaudible] forces kill man,
who refused to give up property Abdul Rakeem all hot tea was allegedly shot
dead. After he refused to give up his property for a red sea mega project.
I'll just.
Meanwhile,
many activists from this tribe living in other parts of the world say that they
are receiving death threats of all canes. The tiger squad sends the messages.
Like don't think that because you live in London, you are safe.
And this explains why these e-sports have also abandoned. Ben Salma,
even gaming companies can only take so much. In this case.
It was the LEC workers themselves that is European league of legends tournament,
who went on strike to force riot games,
to cancel all contracts with Saudi Arabia. And of course,
riot games listened to them. So see, gamers rise up.
This point. There were some problematic sponsors shell and Kit-Kat for example,
but this was a different level.
This is a project to build a mega city directly overseen by a despotic leader of
a country that murders journalists.
I think that was the breaking point for a lot of people, Devin, pure technics,
young league of legends. E-sport commentator.
Two posts by now the message from the whole world to Ben Selman is pretty clear.
Stop killing people. It may seem like stating the obvious.
You may even think that it is so obvious that is some store of black comedy,
but the truth is that for Ben Solman,
this is apparently far from obvious and this situation where the whole world
is turning its back on him. Ben Suleman is not thinking of stopping,
killing people far from it. At the time of making this video,
at least there was no announcement that Saudi Arabia is going to cancel that
tiger squad or that they are considering ending.
The killing the opposite in fact is true after these murders and all these
canceled contracts, Ben Selman is trying a different strategy.
Hiring communications agency
and June,
2020 Saudi Arabia announced contracts worth $3 million with two international PR
agencies versus Kuhn and Wolf and render Finn, frankly,
no matter how many communications campaigns you do,
I doubt very much that murders can be whitewashed,
but apart from human rights violations,
Saudi Arabia is still stuck with the same economic problem.
Think about it for a month.
Then someone is on the ropes. On the one hand,
he needs to get this project off the ground,
no matter what his whole public image is linked to New York, his success,
all Saudi Arabia is diversification plans are linked to neon success as are all
of the mega projects. And without the support of foreign investors,
it is difficult to think that he can carry them out.
And the financial treks he has been using so far are not exactly helping him in
this case. For example,
fluting Aramco on the stock market gave him 26.6 billion,
but that money that came almost entirely from Saudi citizens,
themselves who bought shares after virtually being forced to by the government.
The objective of that operation was to get money from outside the country.
And in that sense, our I'm cause IPU was an absolute failure. No,
it doesn't need 26 billion, but 500 billion.
So the burning questions are well.
We really get to see a Jurassic park in Saudi Arabia and I'd argue, Nope,
because they're animatronic dinosaurs, not real dinosaurs. Watch the movie.
It's pretty clear. Do you really think this mega project,
this neon mega city is a good investment or will it be the ultimate ruin of
Saudi Arabia? And what would you do most importantly,
if you got your own artificial moon,
leave your answers in the comments as always,
we really hope you've enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Also don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals and this episode that we're not my dulcet tones. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always see you next time.
And learn more about politics and world affairs.
And here's some more of my lovely voice. Um,
check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or
Google play or your favorite pod catcher.